[Musique]
je m'appelle Cédric Perin j'ai 49 ans je
suis sénateur depuis 2014 du Territoire
de Belfort et je suis depuis octobre
2023 président de la commission des
affaires étrangères et de la défense des
forces d'armées du Sénat et conseiller
départemental du territoire de
belellefort j'ai adhéré au RPR j'avais
15 ans par intérêt pour la chose
publique parce que j'étais très investi
dans les associations et puis parce que
j'ai toujours été intéressé par la par
la politique j'ai fait des études de
droit et puis un jour on m'a proposé de
me présenter à une élection municipale à
une élection cantonnale et puis j'ai été
élu en 2001 j'étais plus jeune
conseiller général de France à l'époque
puis toute une tout un cheminement
ensuite de de conquête si je puis dire
jusqu'à devenir en 2014 sénateur du
Territoire de
Belfort la commission des affaires
étrangères et de la défense et des
forces armées a pris évidemment une
dimension complètement différente avec
les attentats avec Charlie Hebdo avec le
Bataclan avec la lutte contre le
terrorisme j'ai fait beaucoup beaucoup
de de rapports j'ai travaillé mes
questions et et fait ce pourquoi je suis
venu au Sénat c'est-à-dire travailler le
fond des des sujets en se spécialisant
sur un problème ou un sujet en
particulier et devenir un peu
spécialiste de cette question le rapport
qui m'a plus marqué qui sans doute a
marqué aussi le Sénat c'est celui que
j'ai réalisé en 2017 sur les drones et
on l'a fait avec pour objectif d'abord
d'aboutir à l'armement des drones et
donc la fierté c'est d'avoir réussi à à
convaincre la ministre des armées à
l'époque Florence parli de décider de
l'armement de nos drones et puis aussi
de l'intérêt qu'il y avait à se doter de
drone alors ce rapport j'en suis assez
fier parce que il a fait rayonner le
Sénat il a montré qu'on avait un travail
de fond qu'on pouvait faire des
propositions qui étaient des
propositions non seulement réalistes en
plus
utiles j'attache une importance
particulière à la diplomatie
parlementaire je pense que le rôle du
Sénat le rôle du Parlement c'est aussi
de permettre et bien des contact avec
nos homologues étrangers ou avec des
entreprises enfin avec des pays
étrangers
moi je suis évidemment parfaitement
consciente que je suis ici grâce à mes
élus locaux j'essaie le lundi et le
vendredi d'être préson dans les communes
d'aller rencontrer les maires d'essayer
de d'échanger de comprendre quels sont
leurs difficultés quels sont leurs
problèmes parce que j'ai coutume de dire
et je ne cesse de le répéter que la
vraie vie elle est pas ici au Sénat elle
est dans nos
[Musique]
territoires